I'm really excited.
I'm here in Duke now in Russia at the joint Institute of
nuclear research.
And I'm in the office of URI [inaudible] after whom element
118 was named I'm the first time I've ever been in the office with somebody that
has an element named after him.
And as a bonus next door on the other side of the corridor is the
office of Fleury off after whom element 114 was
named. So two great heroes in one place. Sadly,
he died many years ago,
but his office has been preserved exactly as it was on the day he died.
So we can see lots of the things that belong to him and his books and so on.
So you'll read, perhaps you can take this to the office.
He's a Florida office.
Now he's a small museum and whatever various
possible events will come here, I will be scoffing girls these table.
So these all booms,
we show him in his life are different time and also
he's led her to stop.
So this is a letter written by flurry of, to Stalin.
It begins steer use of this, which,
which is Stalin's first name.
And then he explains the possibilities of using
uranium for a bomb that he says
says that it is almost science fiction, but if it works,
the payoff would be enormous.
He spoke thick and heroic. Yeah.
This is his lab coat. Yeah.
Was he a big man?
Yeah, it's just like me, me and also Amy, by the way,
it was a meeting here. Sometimes
we'll have the fittings at the changes, uptick of his car.
He's very much typical for flora. And if you look on the Blackboard,
now we discussed together with fluoro,
how to make a talkin material. Curium two 50. Yeah.
Having underground explosion. But we small explosion,
which may produce kudos to 50. And he.
You were saying his,
he was proposing an underground nuclear explosion. Exactly.
And to collect the material and from this to make five
micrograms of Cuban Curium and so was the hundred
tons, the, the power of the explosion, correct to you?
Was he, was he like a friend or was he like your boss? What was your,
what was your reaction?
The age difference between me and 20 years.
Of course, I cannot say this and white for that, but, uh,
we worked together many years. See, just after the issue,
they came here in his laboratory until he was
alive, who were working together for me, he was a really
some person, he opened me the science. I mean,
the physics of this problem of the super-heavy was so
fantastically mean for, for yarn guy.
Like I was that they really completely up
to this problem. I would say, if I start out again,
I will take this way from the first meeting with him.
Uh, I was a conversation like that.
He does ask me about the physics.
You just asked me what I'm
like life make I sport.
If I like a theater music,
any other thing? So you actually, it was just a
conversation like that. I said, okay. Okay.
I satisfied. Thank you very much.
I take maybe group.
What's it like for you to come in here today? Like when you,
when you come in here as now that he has died,
does it make you feel any emotion? Does it bring back memories?
Is it just a museum to you? What, what does this room make you feel?
I don't know how to say it in English, but
[inaudible] but he
[inaudible]. So he dreams.
When he sleeps, he dreams is talking to flurry of what does he say to you?
Because, uh, a typical life here at Duke Davos,
uh, after the walking dead, uh,
six o'clock you come, Oh,
a nine o'clock phone. Call what? Goodwill
please? Every day.
And every day from nine to 10, 10 30,
one hour free discussion.
That's very good. Did he live close to you? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And also sometimes he called very early morning
just to say, I'm very sorry. The quality.
So only it seven o'clock in the morning.
How did you feel when they made the decision to name an element after flare off
Ferrovial did you, did this make you feel?
I find that it wasn't mine, but just the ability,
because they mean walk with this bale
all my life. So he's really mean,
unfortunately passed away at that time.
When I say her
wife dawned on me, it's my duty.
If one day I can be scoured, the one
I first name I won't get.
It's really, almost like that.
Professor tomorrow, we see the inauguration of these new elements.
Do you wish he was there tomorrow?
Do you wish he could be with us tomorrow to see this?
[Inaudible] it would be his dream.
If it was a dream at the [inaudible] it would be a dream. The beloved,
which star
[inaudible].
Yes, it was his dream for the new curation of flerovium
and it would also be a dream if he was there tomorrow.
He came from Kamchatka and he took his crap.
This was always on his wall. Was it? Yeah.
Did he catch this or didn't was it given as a gift or was it, was it, was he,
did he cut? Did he catch it?
He mentioned that income sharp [inaudible] crap,
uh, craps com uh, died
and he took one shot should be crap.
What is this.
For discussion? He would tell me.
Was he impatient? It sounds like he was impatient. Hurry up.
When you go to Pena.
So he wasn't very patient. Apparently he wasn't very patient,
so everything had to be done quickly.
And so in this case, they take plutonium,
which is element 94 and to make 114,
you need 20.
So you take a nucleus of calcium,
which has atomic number 20,
you accelerate calcium very rapidly.